>> ABSOLUTELY.
M.J., THANK YOU VERY, VERY MUCH
FOR ALL THAT REPORTING AND
ESPECIALLY THAT CONTEXT AT THE
END.
NOW WE'LL BRING IN DAVID WHELAN,
PAUL'S BROTHER.
DAVID, GOOD MORNING TO YOU.
THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
>> MORNING.
>> LET'S BEGIN WITH YOUR
REACTION TO THE NEWS.
>> IT'S GREAT NEWS.
ANY TIME AN AMERICAN COMES HOME,
IT'S WONDERFUL NEWS.
I'M SO GLAT FOR BRITTANY AND
CHERELLE.
IT'S A WONDERFUL DAY.
>> POWELL HAS BEEN HELD FOR FOUR
YEARS.
THE LAST I READ AND HEARD FROM
YOU ABOUT A WEEK AGO HE WAS IN A
RUSSIAN HOSPITAL.
THE PRESIDENT SAID HE'S TALKED
TO YOU, AS I UNDERSTAND,
YESTERDAY.
CAN YOU SHARE WHAT YOU CAN WITH
US IN TERMS OF THIS
ADMINISTRATION'S EFFORTS TO GET
YOUR BROTHER HOME.
>> SOMEONE FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
LET US KNOW, WHICH WAS VERY
KIND.
IT'S HARD TO PROCESS THIS IN
REALTIME WHICH IS WHAT WE HAD TO
DO LAST APRIL WHEN PAUL WAS LEFT
BEHIND BEFORE AND TREVOR REED
CAME HOME.
IT'S A GREAT DAY FOR FAMILIES OF
THE WRONGFULLY DETAINED AND WE
FEEL WONDERFUL FOR THEM, BUT WE
DO WORRY ABOUT WHAT'S IN PAUL'S
FUTURE.
IT'S BECOME CLEAR THAT THE U.S.
DOESN'T HAVE ANY CONCESSIONS
THAT THE RUSSIAN GOVERNMENT
WANTS FOR PAUL, SO I'M NOT
REALLY SURE WHAT THE FUTURE
HOLDS.
>> LISTEN, I IMAGINE IT'S
BITTERSWEET -- I DON'T KNOW IF
THAT'S THE RIGHT TERM -- BECAUSE
YOU'RE HAPPY FOR BRITTNEY
GRINER'S FAMILY, HER WIFE AND
ALL INVOLVED.
YOU SAID IT'S A GREAT DEAL FOR
ALL PEOPLE WRONGFULLY DETAINED,
BUT YET YOUR BROTHER IS STILL
THERE.
HOW DO YOU NAVIGATE THAT?
WHAT DO YOU THINK MOVING FORWARD
YOUR CONVERSATIONS WITH THE
ADMINISTRATION AND THOSE WHO ARE
INVOLVED IN TRYING TO GET YOUR
BROTHER HOME, WHERE DOES THAT GO
FROM HERE?
>> IT'S THE SAME THING WE'VE
BEEN DOING EVERY DAY FOR THE
LAST 440 DAYS.
WE HEARD THE NEWS YESTERDAY.
I PREPARED MY MEDIA STATEMENT TO
GO OUT THIS MORNING AND WE WERE
BACK TO WORK, CHECKING RUSSIANS
MEDIA, LOOKING FOR OPTIONS THAT
WE COULD SEND ON TO THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT, SUGGESTIONS.
REALLY IT'S A MATTER OF HELPING
PAUL TO SURVIVE UNTIL AND IF THE
U.S. GOVERNMENT IS ABLE TO FIND
A CONCESSION THAT THE RUSSIAN
GOVERNMENT WANTS.
IT'S NOT MAGIC.
IT'S JUST A TON OF WORK.
>> DAVID, YOU HEARD THE
PRESIDENT SAY FOR REASONS HE
SAYS ARE TOTALLY ILLEGITIMATE,
RUSSIA IS NOT TREATING THE
RELEASE OF YOUR BROTHER THE SAME
AS BRITTNEY GRINER.
DID ANYONE FROM THE
ADMINISTRATION TELL YOU WHAT
THEY BELIEVE THOSE REASONS ARE?
>> IT'S NOT CLEAR TO ME WHAT IT
IS.
PROBABLY SOMETHI